I be sure I was interested in a question
about childhood because of this is
certainly a very important especially in
the developing countries because in most
of the agricultural environments you
traditionally have people working with
enjoy working with the Burnet for
example in Switzerland we still give
career in the school children one week
of vacation so that they can help in the
harvest between having children working
it's not easy
most importantly also I would say is for
me even more important and whether they
work or not work is whether they get
access to good education of course
cannot accept absolutely safety which
still exists in some part of Africa so I
hope this has helped you to get one
answer to this to you very very
interesting question Thanks